The answer is that the attacker would expect to need
N/2 times as much.
The reason for this is because of this step.
Bob randomly picks one of the puzzles and solves just that puzzle.
Once Bob has solved it, he sends back the number of the puzzle that he solved,
which was part of the puzzle to Alice,
and that establishes the shared key.
An attacker can hear that number but doesn't know which
of the encrypted messages corresponds to that.
The attacker would need to try and break all of the encrypted messages
and would be expected to find the one that matches the one that Bob picked
after trying about half of them.
This is a neat idea.
That N/2 advantage is really not enough.
For that to be significant, we would have to have a really large number of puzzles.
That involves a lot of work for Alice.
Alice still needs to create all those puzzles.
And it requires a lot of bandwidth.
We'd have to send all those puzzles across the network,
so a very impractical idea.